the jurogan experience what we do
doesn't make sense and i do it
you know like at world's strongest man
in 2019 we had to pull two monster
trucks because one was too light
like come on
like personally that pissed me off
because i suck at that event
yeah yeah and it was a slight incline is
that a weight event like where it helps
to be like a 400 pound guy absolute 280
pound guy with that event mass moves
mass yeah right like yeah so in that
year i had thor in my group
the dude weighed 4 30 4 40 when we were
competing against each other bro he's
pretty light now isn't he yeah he's i
think about 3 30. he's actually right
down the street oh really he's at the
honor gym he put up his uh thor's uh
instagram i knew he was in uh i knew he
was here lately um i know rayne had them
in la and stuff like that he might even
be here this weekend i don't know i
think he's here right now because he he
was at on at gym and he put up video of
him hitting the pads and i have to say
like he's doing everything right
it looks solid he looks really but it's
interesting because he's learning how to
box because he's having these boxing
matches but the way he's doing it is
very intelligent like he's not just like
gritting his teeth and throwing his arms
his heart fart and using all his his
physical muscle power he's learning how
to do it correctly and everything is
like real smooth and polished
when you're fighting like you do have to
be pretty relaxed when you're doing it
you have to be able to generate force
quickly but you also have to be supple
you have to you have to be relaxed
because if you're relaxed you actually
can move faster when you really tense up
and wind up you lose a lot of your
ability to close the distance quick it's
got to be like efficient yeah and the
way you get efficient is by repetition
with proper technique and learning how
to you know hit paths with proper
technique and you know when i first saw
him doing that i was like oh my god
imagine going from being strong man and
being the mountain on game of thrones to
trying to box like this is so awkward
but not anymore man when you see him did
you find
it all
oh maybe it's in the audit gym i was
looking i switched to that and i wasn't
seeing it there either god did maybe
it's one of the trainers
recently yeah today okay maybe it's one
of the trainers i follow that posted it
but uh [ __ ] i i really think it was him
[ __ ]
i mean i know he's in the states right
now because he was just in l.a he's in
austin a week ago he's in austin um
well let's see that that right there see
that right there
that's not at the honor gym that's just
him
yeah he's lost like about a hundred
pounds yeah
he looks great yeah no he looks awesome
it's crazy it's like a totally different
kind of human now you know big time now
he looks like a big athlete i wonder
what his like long-term goals are in
that r i don't know there's a lot of
money in like freak boxing matches i
know you know it's crazy if you get like
logan paul to box the mountain
oh yeah oh yeah
yeah he just he yeah he won but he's
been fighting for a long time now yeah
ever since he stepped out of world's
strongest man he went into the mma
this is an interesting pretty quick guy
watch this right here
boom yeah crazy and the guy who fought
is a giant too yeah
crazy but pujanowski's been fighting in
mma for a long time he fought tim sylvia
who was the former ufc heavyweight
champion and that was a crazy stupid
fight like he got his good no no he got
his ass kicked but i mean like of course
he got his ass kicked yeah he's
literally fighting a former world
champion and he's just a really strong
guy learning how to fight exactly and he
was a guy like when he first started
fighting he could see like he'd hit pads
and he'd be like
all arms just neanderthal yeah but now
he's like throwing his shoulders in and
moving his hips he's become he's got
he's still big as [ __ ] but he's like
he's lost some weight i feel like none
of us strong men are ever going to be
small
right for the rest when you get to this
level like i think you're just like you
know i look at my life and i'm like yeah
probably the lightest i'll ever be is
like 2 30 to 2 40. people are always
coming to you to open the mayonnaise jar
always 100
yeah yeah you're probably always keep i
mean you only lose so much of it you're
not gonna ever be like a marathon runner
i nor do i want to be right watch the
entire episode for free only on spotify